joining me now a Bruno Montaigne he's
retail analyst at Bernstein research and
Adam Leyland's he's editor of The Grocer
gentlemen good evening to you both
Bruno big question is just going to get
pasta cm a most likely yes company like
Sainsbury's and Walmart and as they
wouldn't go into this lightly they've
clearly read the last few filings
whether is it this cookbook a deal for
the choral thing and we clearly
highlighted specific elements of what's
has changed versus ten years ago and
it's probably two particular items are
really worth thinking about 10 years ago
he wider competitor or not and so they
would have considered only big stores a
competitor of another supermarket in
previous filings and made it clear that
discounts are a competitor small so that
are compared even online is a competitor
and so the set of people that compete
with another or the same store is much
more than it was ten years ago which is
probably reality they made it clear on
paper the CMA doesn't have a lot of
flexibility if the rules are there the
precedent I said there they don't do the
numbers this will be approved and of
course the CMA having approved the Tesco
takeover of Booker has almost created
the climate for this deal I don't agree
with that
I mean Tusker Booker was a radically
different deal was retailer of a
wholesaler the CMA follows the rules
they know like have whims that it
answers say I have to keep to this room
there's very clear economic thinking
behind that occasion they're thinking
develops they have to stick to the rules
that they write themselves or that the
government sets for them a testicle
Booker was well thought through it had
to be a proven I think the same will be
do it for this this isn't about the
whims changing him they have to do this
because of the other deal right I mean
Adam it's very clear from what Bruno
saying there that CMA does accept though
that the climate has changed this isn't
like Safeway being bought by Morrison's
fifteen years ago it's a completely
different market the discounters despite
being considerably smaller in share
terms are really hurting as they're in
Sainsbury's as they're you think about
it they have spent so this cut thousands
of jobs ahead of his level they tried
their best to compete on price and they
have fundamentally failed they're still
at 15%
issue sort of margin and if you think of
all that work they're doing it's no
wonder they're saying you know we've
actually an it's ironic isn't it that
these disrupt so this is a consolidation
play
in which to the biggest supermarkets in
the land adjoining forces to compete
with a disrupter now these aren't small
disruptors they are very big Aldi and
Lidl are backed by enormous German based
global businesses so similarly with
Amazon but in terms of share their share
is smaller so really there's a
recognition here that it isn't a share
necessarily that delivers the effective
prices they need to compete against
these more nimble disruptive new models
carnage for the supplies I mean they're
talking about 350 million pounds worth
of savings in the first year alone what
actually actually a lot more than that
because that is a net synergy so what
they're saying is that they can part on
10% price cuts for core every day lines
and then deliver to shareholders 350
million in the synergies so really yes
it is carnage I don't know what is this
trigger therefore more consolidation
among suppliers you know the likes of
Procter & Gamble and Unilever and Kraft
Heinz I think the message from my coop
today was look these large
multinationals make huge margins
compared with the supermarkets and
they're rich enough to afford the sort
of price reductions that they're looking
for they've never been a best of friends
with the big branded suppliers they've
always been quite jealous of the likes
of Tesco and asked their in terms of
their relationship with the brands and
they've done this sort of black box
style interrogation of prices and
they're convinced that there's huge
savings whichever side it comes from but
yes there will be this interrogation
therefore and this harmonization and
equalization of pricing that will
terrify large suppliers
it will also terrify small suppliers but
it would be a huge own goal if
Sainsbury's answer then invested it hit
them as well the likelihood is that they
will subsidize the smaller suppliers not
expect this sort of harmonization of
terms and that they will actually you
know use the big beer brands and the and
the household brands and so forth to get
more for the organic store yeah exactly
Bruno what about the number of stores
that the CMA are likely to ask them to
close I mean my coop very coy on this he
must have a number in mind what do you
think it is
it's anybody's guess but I mean it's not
gonna be more than 10% because if not
economics would probably get quite
difficult for the deal
much less than five I mean I think any
number between three and eight sounds
about right to me is still a pretty
broad band but this would be much more
than the 20% we would have expected if
this deal had been done ten years ago
all right in a montane adam Leyland
thanks both good see